Harry: From calorie
count to portion sizes,
we wanted to find out all the differences
between Little Caesars
in the US and the UK.
This is "Food Wars."
Little Caesars in the US
sells Hot-N-Ready pizzas
in one size, 14 inches.
Closer to 13 ½. I'll let it slide, though.
In the UK, Little Caesars
Hot-N-Ready pizzas
only come in one size, 12 inches.
That means that the surface area
of a UK Little Caesars pizza
is 113.1 square inches.
The surface area of a
US Little Caesars pizza
is 153.94 square inches.
That makes the pizza 36%
larger than the UK's.
Now, we can get Crazy Bread in the UK,
and we ordered it from our Little Caesars,
but unfortunately they forgot it.
If they remember your Crazy Bread,
it looks like you get
four pieces with an order,
according to the website.
Too bad for the UK, but the US,
we did get our Crazy Bread,
and an order of Crazy Bread
comes with eight sticks.
Eight crazy sticks.
It wouldn't, of course,
be a order of Crazy Bread
without the Crazy Sauce.
To add insult to injury,
they gave us just the Crazy
Sauce, but without the bread.
Let's weight it anyway
to see how much we get.
A side of Crazy Sauce in
the UK weighs 7 grams.
Joe: It's 159 grams.
Whoa, it's so crazy!
No. It's not, of course. It's fine.
I wouldn't call the sauce crazy.
Misunderstood, maybe, but it feels like
the sauce kind of has it under control.
This is a very mild-mannered,
well-thought-out, well-measured sauce.
Another item available in both
countries is cheese bread.
I'll say on the
medium-rare side of cooked.
7.5 inches across, and 5.5 inches wide.
I would like to note that in the US,
our cheese bread is called
Italian cheese bread.
Ooh, that's almost exactly 9 inches.
7 inches.
If you want to get a small
pizza at a Little Caesars,
just get the Italian cheese
bread and a side of sauce.
Some assembly required.
Here are all the Little
Caesars menu items in the UK
that you won't find in the US.
Here is all of the
Little Caesars menu items
you can get in the US that
you won't find in the UK.
Before we talk about some of
the default pizza options,
we'll talk about some of
the customization options
you get in the UK that you
guys can't change in the US.
For example, over here we can
sub out the tomato sauce base
for barbecue sauce or peri-peri sauce.
I think the peri-peri
sauce is kind of a nod
to the UK's obsession with peri-peri.
You guys know how much
we love our Nando's.
I think Little Caesars are
trying to get in on that as well.
Nando's just dropped to
their knees in Tesco,
just like, oh, my God, no.
The peri-peri option doesn't stop there,
because you can also
add peri-peri seasoning
to the crust of your
pizza at Little Caesars.
The US customizations.
For the crust, round,
which I guess is regular.
But we also have thin
crust, stuffed crust,
Detroit-style deep dish,
and stuffed-crust deep dish.
For bake, we also do a well done.
Cheese, you can get,
obviously regular cheese,
but no cheese or light cheese.
Sauce, same thing, light,
normal, extra, no sauce.
Now let's talk about some of
the pizza options in the UK
you won't find on the menu in the US.
Here we have the barbecue chicken pizza.
If you stare at this thing for too long,
you will be lured into a hypnotic trance.
The barbecue sauce is very sweet
and kind of becomes the main
thing that you can taste.
If that's your thing,
do it. Not really mine.
Over this way, we have
the spicy peri-peri.
The peri-peri is quite gentle.
Just, like, a little bit of heat, maybe.
But to call that a spicy peri-peri,
I think they've oversold the spicy,
and they've also kind of
oversold the peri-peri.
Our next pizza is this one.
It's called the quattro.
What they've done is take a pizza
and divide it into fours and
then top those individually.
So you have two slices of Margherita,
two slices of pepperoni, two
slices chicken and mushroom,
and two slices of peppers,
tomatoes, and sweet corn.
All right, this says "SC pepperoni,"
stuffed-crust pepperoni.
I mean, this looks, like,
I mean, pretty generous
with the pepperoni.
It's a bit more
neon-colored than I'd like.
The crust, of course, is
stuffed with mozzarella cheese.
Eh, yeah, not bad.
Let's just try.
Sorry, stuffed crust.
People just kind of don't care about it.
Something newer to the Little
Caesars menu here in the US,
there's something called Slice-N-Stix,
which is half pizza, half breadsticks.
For the consumer who
wants a little variety,
just them by themselves don't
want to get a whole pizza
and a whole thing of sticks.
I want to point out that Slice-N-Stix
come in what I think is
this, aka the classic.
But you also get bacon Slice-N-Stix
and jalapeño Slice-N-Stix.
Throw on your grass skirts,
ladies and gentlemen.
We're going to Hawaii.
This is the Hula Hawaiian,
which of course is bacon and pineapple.
I think pineapple on
pizza's perfectly fine.
This Hawaiian's not very good, but.
The before-mentioned thin crust.
Thin-crust pepperoni.
It's pretty good, if you want
to pay the exact same price
for literally half the pizza.
So far for Little Caesars,
the pepperoni's winning across the board.
Little Caesars got me through
some financial rough patches,
so I don't want to be too hard on them.
But, I mean, I'm eating it, I'm like,
oh, yeah, my early 20s. Great.
5 Meat Feast. Count with me here.
Pepperoni, ham, sausage, hamburger?
Bacon, and, yeah, I think
it's, like, a seasoned beef.
I don't like when they go ham and pork
are two different meats. I
know they're two different,
but it's kind of like,
they're pretty close.
Or it should be five meats, two animals.
The seasoned ground beef or sausage
looks a lot like mouse turds,
making this incredibly unappetizing.
[mouse squeaks]
You're trying too hard with this one.
Then we have a few
deluxe options in the UK,
starting with a pepperoni deluxe.
If you're wondering what makes this deluxe
when compared to a standard pepperoni,
they just take some extra
pepperoni and add it to the pizza
and then sprinkle it
with Grana Padano cheese.
I will say, like, it does look
slightly more deluxe than the rest.
Let's see if it tastes deluxe.
It might just be a placebo effect,
but it does kind of taste like
the best one I've had so far.
I don't know if I'd stretch
to deluxe as an adjective,
but slightly better for sure.
Maybe just rename it the
slightly better pepperoni.
Something that here in the
US our Little Caesars has --
I've never heard of this before,
and I don't know exactly
what they're doing --
a series of pizzas, two pizzas,
called, and this is all one word,
Extramostbestest.
The Extramostbestest cheese and pepperoni.
Is this just rebranding the
plain cheese and the plain?
What makes this Extramostbestest?
All right, let's find out together.
It's an upgrade take on
their classic pepperoni pizza
that offers 80% more pepperoni,
uses 25% more cheese.
OK, so more cheese and more pepperoni.
Wait a second, wait a
second, wait a second.
Can someone grab a screenshot of that?
We'll compare this to,
there's a pepperoni that's coming up
that has a lot more on here, so.
Next up is another deluxe option.
The Margherita deluxe.
Just as a linguistic note, in the UK,
if you see a cheese-and-tomato
pizza on the menu,
it's almost always referred
to as a Margherita.
Everyone knows what that means.
It's a slightly more
traditional Italian way
of saying cheese and tomato.
Whereas in America, it seems like you guys
all just have to say cheese pizza
or you don't really understand
what you're getting.
To turn this Margherita
into a deluxe version,
it seems like all they've really done
is added, I think, some herbs
and then some chopped-up
pieces of actual tomato.
All I really have to
say about most of these
is that they're fine.
Our final deluxe pizza exclusive
is the mushroom deluxe.
Again, it looks like a fairly
standard mushroom pizza,
with, I think, the herbs again
and the Grana Padano
sprinkled around the edge.
It's also funny that they call this one
a mushroom deluxe pizza,
because there isn't actually
a standard mushroom on the menu.
So I guess if you like
mushrooms on your pizza,
you're being forced into having
the deluxe, fancy version.
This [drumroll]
is the Old World Fanceroni Pepperoni.
Guh-roan.
Now that's pepperoni! Let's go!
The cups? Oh, yeah!
Now, remember that one a
minute ago that we just saw
that was the Extrabestmostest
or whatever the hell it's called?
Yes. Yes!
Oh, they're crispy!
This is pretty good.
I will say, the dough on all these pizzas
are a lot spongier.
I'm hoping that that is a
choice to make it spongier
and not that they just
didn't cook these through.
I'll find out in a couple hours.
Of the regular round pizzas,
last and certainly least, veggie.
As before mentioned,
a version of pizza you
can get here in the US,
we have a Detroit-style deep-dish
pizza at Little Caesars.
You can get the ultimate
supreme, the veggie,
the pepperoni, the 3 Meat,
Hawaiian, and just regular cheese.
I went with the pepperoni
because I feel that's
classic Detroit style.
Hm.
Detroit, let us know in
the comments how they did.
True Detroit style puts the sauce,
or a little bit of sauce
on top. They did not.
So it just looks like
a really thick pizza.
We love our bread in this country.
I would suggest against
selling this in Detroit.
So, what we have here
is the UK-only pizza.
What we've done is take all
of the customization options
you can only find in the UK
and combine them onto one pizza.
So what this pizza has is
the peri-peri sauce base,
a barbecue sauce drizzle,
peri-peri chicken,
regular chicken, red onions,
sweet corn, and tomatoes.
Honestly, that's not terrible.
Far from the worst UK-only
creation that we've ever made.
The peri sauce base seems
to just be tomato sauce
with a bit of peri seasoning
kind of mixed into it.
So you still get a bit of
the sweetness from the tomato
and a very gentle warmth from that.
The barbecue sauce is kind
of the dominant flavor again,
but as far as UK-only
pizzas go, it's not bad.
A segment that, Yuelei,
we haven't done this in
forever, it feels like!
A USA-only! That's right!
This is a pizza you can only get
in the United States of
America at a Little Caesars.
Of all the many USA-only options,
we went with a well-done
pizza with a stuffed crust,
extra sauce, light cheese,
Old World pepperoni,
pineapple, and black olives.
Oh, man. Wah-wah.
The extra sauce I think
is what really -- oh, God.
The extra sauce is what
really ruined this,
'cause now it's just all sliding off.
Ah.
It's really bad.
And it's really bad
because it's falling apart.
And also we got this separately,
so this actually just
came out of the oven.
It's really hot.
Then we're on to the sides.
We have two exclusives in the UK.
Now, while we didn't get
any of the Crazy Bread,
at least we got the Crazy Puffs.
They take the dough,
they form it into a kind
of cupcake, muffin shape,
which is then filled
with some tomato sauce
and cheese and pepperoni.
You can see the grease,
like, dripping out of that
as soon as I bit in.
They're not bad.
They're on a mid-level of the crazy scale.
And we can also get veggie Crazy Puff.
It's the same cheese and sauce base,
but then instead of the pepperoni,
they've added corn, peppers, and onion.
We also have stuffed Crazy Bread.
Remember that Crazy Bread from earlier?
Now it's stuffed.
What the?
This is like a giant mozzarella stick.
Isn't really melted.
Oh, man, remarkably bland. Avoid.
Caesars' got wings.
Oven-roasted, barbecue, and Buffalo.
I'm starting to get a headache.
I can't for the life of me
pinpoint what is making
me suddenly so nauseous.
We have a couple of
exclusive sauces in the UK,
which means it's time for:
Sauce Talk.
We have three sauces in the UK
that you won't find on an American menu,
which is garlic and herb.
When you order at Domino's,
it comes by default
with a garlic and herb dip in the UK.
People go crazy for that
dip. People really love it.
So a few other places
have tried to kind of
jump on that bandwagon,
and this is their version.
We then have a peri-peri sauce,
and finally we have a ketchup on the menu.
I'm questioning anybody who
eats pizza with ketchup.
I'm gonna be honest.
And we don't really even have any sides
on the menu that go with ketchup, so.
The garlic and herb is defeating me.
Leon, help.
[glass breaks]
It's got quite a harsh taste, actually.
Surprisingly harsh.
Try the peri-peri.
So, the thing is, peri-peri
has a very distinct flavor.
It's a specific type of chili.
All I'm really getting
from this is just, like,
chili-pepper heat. No.
You have ketchup.
Can't quite put my finger on it.
I'm going to literally
put my finger on it.
It's got almost more of, like,
a tomato-soup flavor to it,
which I don't hate.
After my preamble about
how much I do not think
ketchup should go with any
of these pizzas, it actually
ended up being my favorite
of these three sauces.
I think that's more of a comment
on the other two not being very nice
rather than the ketchup being good.
You have a variety of four exclusive
delicious dipping sauces.
Butter garlic flavor,
Buffalo ranch,
cheezy jalapeño,
and just regular ranch.
Little Caesars in the UK
also has one dessert option
you won't find in the US,
chocolate chip cookies.
So, we got desserts.
Cookie dough brownies.
One has Twix pieces,
the other has M&M minis.
Very, very sweet.
Kind of weird, actually.
Finally, let's talk about drinks.
In the UK, Little Caesars
carries Coca-Cola branded drinks,
including, obviously, Coca-Cola,
but then also things like
Monster Energy and Oasis,
which is a bit of a British classic.
Comes in either citrus
punch or summer fruits.
It's kind of like a diluted
fruit juice. Refreshing.
Finally, I can have something to drink.
They had Coke products.
We got Pepsi products.
Oh, you know, the classic Pepsi.
Mug root beer, Mountain Dew,
and Starry!
It's the new one. It's
what replaced Sierra Mist.
RIP Sierra Mist, thank God.
Yeah, that's, like, exactly
what 7Up tastes like.
They invented 7Up. Great job, guys.
Unfortunately, Little Caesars in the UK
doesn't give us a full nutritional
breakdown, only calories.
A Hot-N-Ready cheese pizza
in the UK is 1,700 calories.
That's 85% of your
recommended daily allowance.
A Hot-N-Ready US cheese
pizza is 1,950 calories.
That's 97.5% of your
recommended daily intake.
Also, the sodium.
Good Lord.
160% of your recommended daily intake.
The most calorific pizza in
the UK is this, 3 Meat Treat.
A whole one of these
contains 1,910 calories,
or 95.5% of your daily allowance.
We also have the 3 Meat Treat,
but ours is 2,870 calories.
That's 960 calories more
than the UK version.
And ours is 143.5% of your daily calories.
You're not going to believe this.
The 3 Meat Treat isn't
our biggest-caloried pie.
That award goes to, oddly enough, this:
the pepperoni and cheese
stuffed-crust pizza.
This whole thing, 3,340 calories.
That's 167% of your daily calorie intake.
And, of course, the sodium.
The sodium!
380% your recommended daily sodium intake.
So, the pizza's cut in eight slices.
So one slice contains
1,094 milligrams of sodium,
which is almost half of your daily amount
in just one slice.
RIP my kidneys.
A Hot-N-Ready Margherita
or pepperoni in the UK
will cost you £5,
which at the time of
recording this is $6.04.
A Little Caesars Hot-N-Ready pizza
has become a contentious topic
in the US in recent years.
Forever, this was just $5.
But in 2022, they raised the price
for the first time in nearly 25 years.
Price can vary depending on your location,
but where I am here in
Southern California,
a Hot-N-Ready cheese pizza is now $6.49,
or £5.40.
Our most expensive pizzas
are the ultimate supreme,
spicy peri-peri, barbecue
chicken, and 3 Meat Treat,
which will all cost you £10.
This was my first time
trying Little Caesars pizza,
because currently there is only
one of them in the whole UK.
It's in Chellaston, just near Derby.
Having now tried it, and also
with the context of the price,
I think I'm fairly confident in saying
this is a pretty low-rung pizza.
It is very rare to find
anything of this size
for £5 in the UK when you come to pizzas.
But in kind of return for that,
you're not getting the best quality.
I think in terms of my taste
of pizza power rankings
for the UK, this would
be sitting fairly low.
But for £5, it's kind of hard to complain,
because that is quite cheap.
I don't know. How do
you feel about it, Joe?
When researching for this video,
I looked it up, and I was
surprised to find out,
and you might be surprised
as well to learn this,
Little Caesars is the third-biggest
pizza chain in America.
Totally surprised.
Little Caesars recently became
the official pizza of the NFL.
What?
I always thought, this
is just me talking here,
Little Caesars was always
the cheapest option.
Also the quality was never that good.
So I was surprised to learn
that this pizza is, A, still around,
B, very popular,
and, C, after this video, not that bad.
I dogged on Little Caesars for a while,
but, I mean, I've had worse.
I've been asked by my producer
to wipe up the crumbs.
One thing Little Caesars
didn't provide were napkins.
That's OK.
Let me wipe my mouth real quick.
Mm!
This video, sponsored by Domino's.
Ah!
Caesar!
Et tu, Brute?